To get started with
SleepingInTheLibrary,
you'll want to download
the starter project for the app.
The download link is posted
in the instructor notes.
The UI is already built for this app, so
we can focus on just
the networking aspects.
If we run the app,
we have a title label at the top, and
then we have a button at the bottom
that'll grab a new image from Flickr.
Right now, if we tap the button,
it just disables the UI and it waits for
an image to be loaded from Flickr.
Back in our Story Board, we can
see that there's an image view for
our image, as well as a label,
this photo title label that we
can use to display any text
associated with the image.
Then in the viewController.swift file,
we have a single action,
grabNewImage, that's called
when the button is pressed.
In the action, we disabled the UI so
that we can't ask for
a new image while waiting for
another image to load.
And then we call
the getImageFromFlickr method.
This is where we'll start
writing our networking code.
First, we'll create the NSURL.
We can do this directly just by copying
the URL like we saw in the API Explorer.
But from a design standpoint something
doesn't really feel right about this.
It's not very maintainable.
What if the names for the arguments
change, or we want to change the URL and
use different arguments?
It'd be much better if we
broke this URL to pieces.
The good news is, is we're going to
help you out a little bit.
If you've been poking around,
you may have noticed that we've created
a separate Swift file,
Constants.swift, where we've defined
all the constants for doing just that,
breaking the URL into pieces.
Here in this file there are structs
that contain constants for
the different parameter keys and
values that we want to use in our URL.
So what's with the static keyword and
also what are the structs that are
contained within the constant struct?
First, the static keyword,
it's similar to the class keyword.
And what it's doing here is it's saying,
this Method property,
it doesn't belong to FlickrParameterKeys
struct instances, but
instead it belongs to
the whole struct itself.
Now, that may sound a little confusing,
but the benefit of this approach is that
we can refer to these constant values
using a really nice dot notation,
and it's very intuitive.
So let me show you
what I'm talking about.
And this is also going to help explain
the structs within structs that we
saw in the constants file.
So if we want to specify the method,
let me make sure which one that is, so
FlickrPrameterKeys, and
then the method value, we can do this.
And just like that, we're referring to a
constant in this very nice dot notation
that kind of goes left to right and
it reads in a very intuitive way.
Similarly, we could specify the API
key by going Constants.Flickr.
Nope it's in Flickr, I think values,
ParameterValues, here we go.
API key.
Like so.
And because of each of these properties,
the method and
the API key are declared as static,
we never have to make instants of
the constant struct to use them.
Now you don't have to do it this way but
we've chosen it because it's a nice way
to maintain all the constant values
in one place,
where we can easily change them.
Now, back in the view controller, we can
use these constants to build the URL.
And I'll add a print statement for
good measure.
So let's build and run, and
test if our URL is what we want.
And this is not bad.
You'll notice that in
the API key argument
here I have the YOUR API KEY value.
You want to substitute
your API key in there.
But I think we can do
a lot better than this.
This might be harder to see
than the first one was.
I propose that we optimize the building
of our URL by creating a method that
formats all of the arguments.
And this will be more
reusable obviously, and
it'll also give us an opportunity
to escape any of the characters
in the arguments that might
include unsafe ASCII characters.
Let's do this next.